Cyber security is one of the fastest
growing and most respected fields today
and earning your CIS certification can
open the door to some of the highest
paying and most trusted roles in the
industry. But passing the SIS isn't just
about memorizing facts. It's about
understanding how to think like a
security leader. That's exactly what
this course is designed to do. I will
walk you through every domain, simplify
complex topics and share real world
example that will help you not only pass
the exam but truly master cyber
security. So before we begin, like this
video, hit that subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell.
Welcome to our last domain, domain
number eight, software development
security. So this is a short domain but
important one. So let's get started.
What is SDLC? That is software
development life cycle and why security
matters in SDLC.
So SDLC is iterative process to develop
update and improve software based on the
user or customer needs. So the phases in
SDLC follow a logical order such as
initially in the first phase we gather
the requirements then we design the
system then the actual development of
the software through coding then testing
and then deployment of the software or
replication in production environment.
So security must be integrated in every
phase. So that is the important point
but not added at the end. So security
should be included from the very start
that is during requirement gathering and
must be included in all subsequent
phases. So the CIS role in SDLC is to
define security requirements guide
developers and ensure secure design and
testing. So CIS does not or do not need
to do the actual coding or develop the
software but to define and look for the
security requirement in the development.
So we need to distinguish between SDLC
which deals with the development of the
software from the SLC which is software
life cycle which is the full system life
cycle that also includes the operation
of the system the maintenance as well as
the final disposal.
So what are the core software
development life cycle phases? So the
first one is the initiation where the uh
we define the business need for the
development.
We document the requirements and approve
the resources from the management.
Second phase is the actual development
where we design the architecture
actually create the code and integrate
the purchased or external component if
there are any.
Then we finally deploy or deliver the
product. So in this phase we release
system into the operational or
productional environment. We perform the
functional and security testing
and then we have the operations and
maintenance which is an ongoing process.
So during this phase we regularly apply
patches
apply the updates to the software as per
the requirements and we do all the
patches and updates as per the change
management. So SDLC can restart when
requirements evolve. So if there are
requirements
uh new requirements that should be
integrated into the system then the
whole process of SDLC again restarts
and the final phase is the disposal
which is the secure decommissioning and
during decommissioning we need to
migrate data from the decommission
application to archive data if required.
sanitize the media and the application
as well as the secure media handling.
So now coming over to software
development life cycle models. How do we
develop uh software through different
methodology or through different
software development life cycle models.
So the development methodologies include
the waterfall. So the waterfall is a
linear and strict phase completion. We
will study waterfall in detail in
upcoming slides.
Then we have the prototyping which works
in iterative measure which it it is
basically uh improves the application
based on the user feedback. So we get
feedback from the user then iterate the
process and improve it.
Then we have some modern approaches such
as agile and devops. So these are
continuous flexible and they give
incremental updates to the software in
chart
phases or short circles. We will study
these in upcoming slides as well.
So first of all the waterfall model. So
what is the waterfall model? So it is
one of the oldest SDLC models. It is
sequential that is it is in an order and
it is noniterative. Noniterative means
that we cannot go back from previous uh
phase to the from uh current phase to
the previous phase. For example, if we
have these phases requirement, design,
implementation, testing, development and
maintenance. So this is a oneway
traffic. What does this mean? This mean
that you go from this phase to next
phase. But let's suppose if at testing
you discover that there is some issue
with design you cannot iterate or you
cannot come back to this phase. So you
can say this is a very rigid and
noniterative model. So the pro progress
flows in one direction that is from
start to the end and there is no going
back once phase is completed. So you
cannot go from development back to the
testing. So it works best when all
requirements are known up front or at
the beginning and the requirements are
unlikely to change. So these are
important points to consider and
remember.
So this is uh as we studied how the
water uh fall model is. Let me clear
this.
So as we can see this is a one-way
process. It is called waterfall model
because if water flows let's suppose
here this water cannot go back
naturally. So that's why this is named
after this natural phenomena. So we
cannot go from this current phase to the
previous phase.
So what are the pros and cons of the
waterfall model? So the advantages
include that the strict it implements
strict documentation and formal
processes and it uh has the strong
support for security requirements and
thorough testing and it has the
predictable schedule and deliverable
because we know all the requirement up
front and we know that in how much time
we will uh deliver the product because
there is no uh change of requirement
during the development or due after the
project development is started.
So limitation or cons of waterfall uh
include that it is highly inflexible.
It cannot handle the changing
requirements.
It is poor fit for modern dynamic
systems and fast changing security
needs. and it has the risk of delivering
a system that no longer meets user need
by the end. So if you go through all
these phases and let's suppose if you
reach the end of the phase where you
finally develop the product,
the user requirements may no longer be
met by this product because no user
input was included during the
intermediate stages.
So then we have another model that is
Agile. So what is Agile? So Agile was
created by agile alliance in 2001 as a
flexible alternative to rigid models
like waterfall. So it is based on the
agile manifestos 12 principle. So these
are guiding values or principles and not
a strict methodology.
So it the agile basically emphasizes
early and continuous delivery of working
software and it is designed to adopt
quickly to changing business and
security requirements. So it is you can
say exactly opposite to the waterfall
model.
So key agile principle include deliver
early and continuously. So it supports
availability plus faster security
feedback welcome changing requirement.
So it easily incorporate new security
control for example encryption and
validation.
It has the iterative development. So
smaller releases reduce risk and allow
frequent reassessment of the threats. So
in waterfall we deliver the big final
product at the end while this agile
model it has the iterative development
methodology where we releases small
updates or development frequently. So
cross functional team. So this requires
security involvement in the requirement
design and testing
agile testing approaches. So testing is
integrated not a separate late phases
like a waterfall. So in waterfall we
have a phase at the end that was testing
while in agile testing is you can say
integrated and it is included from the
very beginning. So automated testing
improves speed, consistency and early
detection of bugs and vulnerabilities.
So each iteration includes lesson
learned plus updated security
requirements. So the goal is to prevent
defects from reaching production through
small frequent and testable changes.
Agile development methodologies. So as
we said that agile itself is not a
methodology. It is a manifesto or
guidance. So based on agile we have
different development methodologies. So
agile principles are implemented through
various methodologies and common agile
based methodologies of SDLC include XP
or extreme programming testdriven
development TDD and scrum. So we will
study these one by one. So first is the
extreme programming or XP. So in XP we
have cross functional teams that is we
have the teams comprising of developers,
customers and managers. So uses it XP
uses user stories and value based
prioritization. It gives the uh value to
the user feedback and user uh let's say
recommendations.
So the pair programming improves code
quality and oversight. So in XP we have
pair programming. What does this mean?
This means that there is a developer one
person develops the code while the
second person reviews the code manually
reviews the code. So this improves the
code quality and also includes the
oversight. Refratoring removes obsolete
or redundant code which reduces the
attack surface. So in XP we have the
refactoring which removes the obsolete
or unused code. In this way it uh
removes or reduces the attack surface of
the application by removing the uh
unused or uh function or security code
that is not required.
Then we have the testdriven development
TDD. So in this method the methodology
is to write the test first and then
write code to make the test pass. So
this ensures clarity on expected
functionality.
So it is useful for security fixes for
example patching buffer overflows and
injection flaws and this methodology
minimizes unintended changes in existing
systems.
Then we have the next agile methodology
that is scrum. So in scrum we have some
key roles. First is the scrum master. So
the scrum master basically removes the
blockers or you can say obstacles
uh in the project and facilitate uh
facilitates the processes. You can say
it is just uh type uh like like a
manager that overall provide resources,
facilitate processes and removes any
pediments. Then we have the product
owner. So the product owner basically
represents the customer and manages the
product backlog. And then the actual
development team. So this team include
the developer, the architects, the
quality assurance team and security
testers.
So we have these artifacts in the
scrums. We have the product backlog
which includes all the requirements of
the project or the uh
and you can say application and these
are prioritized by value. So we have all
the requirements and their priority is
uh such that they are prioritized by the
value of these requirements to the
system. Then we have the sprint backlog
which is which are selected items to be
completed in the current sprint. So
sprint are you can say it is uh these
are cycles you can say the iterative
processes during the overall development
project and the sprint are shortterm you
can say phases for example 2 weeks 4
weeks uh or 2 months and the spring
backlogs basically include the
requirements or the items that need to
be included in that specific print.
What are the core activities in scrum?
So these include the sprint which is the
fixed time box for example two weeks to
deliver the working features.
We have the sprint planning which is
used to select the backlog items during
this uh sprint. Scope should not change
midsprint. So when we select the item
that will be completed in the sprint
then the scope of these items should not
change during the middle of the sprint
because again sprint is the uh test uh
you can say uh a runtime or a phase. So
you cannot just change requirement in
the middle of the you can say two week
duration. Then we have the daily scrum
which is the quick standup for the
current status and the blockers.
Then we have the sprint review which is
the demo completed demonstration of
completed work to the stakeholders and
retrospective which include lesson
learned plus improvement for the next
sprint.
Our next topic is the dev ops. So DevOps
integrates development plus separation
plus quality assurance into one
collaborative team.
So DevOps solves issues from siloed
handoffs. It improves communication and
delivery speed. DevOps uses automation,
frequent testing
and continuous integration, continuous
deployment that is CI/CD pipeline.
So the goal of DevOps is to deliver
software faster without sacrificing on
the security.
So how do we implement security in
DevOps? So the QA defines success
criteria early and provides quick
feedback via automated test. So the
emphasis here is on automated test. So
the test in DevOps are automated and so
when the tests are automated it means we
can run these test frequently and during
each phase and they provide quick
feedback. The automated security testing
helps detect vulnerabilities earlier.
They reduces bugs reaching the end
production system and they speed up the
patching. So security must be embedded
in every stage of the pipeline that is
security should be built in
faster software de delivery must not
bypass security control. So the dev
devops basically delivers fast delivery
of software but again the security
control and security needs should not be
bypassed or compromised and for this we
have the integrated automated testing of
the security controls.
What is the governance and access
control in DevOps? So DevOps roles often
hold privileged access such as uh
changes to the production system, user
creation and logs. So these are the
access that h that the DevOps role uh
has. So this requires strong controls.
For example, the roles must have least
privilege, separation of duties and
multiffactor authentication.
Due to these uh privilege uh action that
these role can perform as well as the
monitoring. So automated tools must
validate test before the deployment of
the application and developers can mark
code ready but another role must approve
the deployment. As we said this is known
as the separation of duty. So one uh
developer can mark the code ready but
then there should be another role that
approves this code. The developer should
not be able to mark the code ready as
well as approve it.
Our next topic is deos ops. So deac ops
integrate security into every phase of
devops pipelines. It means security at
the devops speed.
It delivers working security controls
now improved continuously and prevents
delays caused by seeking perfection. So
security becomes a shared responsibility
across development, operation and
security teams
and it uses automation for code
scanning, configuration checks,
compliance and vulnerability testing.
What are the core principle and security
comes of dev sec ops? So the real world
testing focus dev ops has the real world
testing focus. It means that the red
blue team exercises are preferred over
theoretical scans
and it has datadriven decision not fear
uncertaintity and doubt that is heard
fear uncertaintity and doubt and there
is continuous corabulation across all
roles. So the results are fewer
vulnerabilities
reach the end production system. We have
faster and safer deployment
uh with integrated continuous
integration and continuous delivery
security checks and actionable risk
insights based on actual exploit
testing. So there is no single test uh
no single standard organization adopt
dev sec ops to meet their environment.
Our
next topic is the maturity model. So
what are the maturity model? They are
framework used to measure the
organizational capability and guide
continuous improvement. So the maturity
model basically provide a baseline, a
target state and a path for improvement
that is process refinement.
Higher maturity means formal, repeatable
and wellmanaged processes versus ad hoc
or chaotic ones. So if we have ad hoc or
chaotic processes, it means we have the
less maturity. On the other hand, if we
have far more repeatable and
well-managed processes, it means the
organization has higher maturity level.
So the maturity models are applicable to
software development, security
operations and service-based IT
environments.
So common maturity model components are
CMM
components. So these includes the
domains. So these are the functional
areas the model actually measures. For
example, the measurement, analysis, and
documentation.
Each domain contains defined practices
such as how metrics are collected and
how often they are collected.
Then we have the uh CMM maturity levels.
So maturity models use progressive
levels often from 1 to five showing the
increased capability. What does this
mean? This mean that level one has low
capability while level five has the
highest capability. So each level has
evaluation criteria used by internal
teams or external auditor to determine
the current maturity and labels may
apply to individual process areas or to
the organizational
overall.
So we may apply the maturity level
either to individual areas or to
individual processes or to the over or
all the processes of the organization.
Then we have the criteria. So to reach a
certain level an organization must meet
all the required practices for that
level. So lower level basically focus on
basics ad hoc that is the documented
processes and higher levels introduce
advanced practices which are basically
metricdriven analysis and continuous
improvement. So some models assign
maturity by domain others assign
maturity per level across all domains.
What are the targets? So the target
maturity level is the desired state
based on the business goals and cost
benefit tradeoff. So higher maturity
reduces risk but also increases cost and
complexity.
So the targets help perform gap analysis
and prioritize the improvements of the
uh organization and the uh required
processes. So in some industries for
example the government contracting
certain maturity levels may be required.
So they may be required by the laws. Uh
for example some government agencies or
government may require that the
contractors
may have certain level of maturity for
example that supposed level or for them
to be able to work with the government.
capability maturity model that is CMM.
So this was development by DoD
department of defense and software
engineering institute of Carnegi Milan
University to evaluate and improve
software development quality.
So this was created in response to
poorly managed and unpredictable
software projects in the 1980s
and it was originally designed to assess
government contractors capability that
is on time and on budget delivery of the
contractor projects but its success led
to adoption across broader business and
development processes.
So capability maturity model integration
that is CMMI.
So evolution of CMM to it is the
evolution. CMMI is the evolution of CMM
to unify and expand maturity modeling
across business areas.
It has different versions including the
CMMI-DEV
that is uh related to development or
deals with development. CMMI-
SVC that is services and CMMI-C
sq that is acquisition.
So CMMI is now managed by the Isaka's
CMMI institute and it supports agile and
cyber maturity programs.
What are some CMMI maturity levels? So
CMMAI has five maturity level. First one
is the initial which is ad hoc,
unpredictable and reactive.
In manage we have project level
processes
uh but they are inconsistent.
Third level is defined where we have
organizationwide
proactive processes.
Fourth maturity level is the
quantitatively managed where metrics are
used to measure and control the
processes.
And fifth last and fifth and the last
maturity level is the optimizing where
we have continuous improvement using
lessons learned and the analysis.
OASP software assurance maturity model
or SMM.
So what is software assurance security
model? So it is a prescriptive OAS
framework for building and improving a
software security program. It integrates
security activities into the existing
software development life cycle and it
is not a replacement of the SDLC itself.
So, SMM basically provides a map, a road
map.
It assesses the current state and then
defines the target maturity. Then
implement the improvements across
processes, people, knowledge and tools.
So, the structure of SMM is that it is
organized into domains and each split
into security practices. So each
practice contains two activity streams.
For example, the automated versus manual
testing responsibility.
Practices have three maturity levels
progressing from basic to fully
integrated security activities.
So we have the SMM domains and security
testing examples. So software assurance
maturity model domains include
governance. So governance includes
strategy and metrics, policy and
compliance and education and guidance.
Then we have the design domain which
include threat assessment, security
requirements and security architecture.
Then we have the implementation
which includes secure build, secure
development and defect management. Then
we have the verification which is are
include architecture assessment
requirements driven testing and security
testing. Finally we have the operations
which include incident management
environment management and operational
management.
The security testing maturity level
example. For example, in level one, we
have basic manual plus automated testing
to find the defects. In level two, we
have more complete testing using the
automation plus schedule manual pen
testing.
In level three, we have the security
testing fully integrated into
development and deployment pipelines.
Our
next topic is O andM that is ongoing
security controls and maintenance.
So we have the vulnerability and page
management which is an ongoing O&M
process. It includes regular scanning
for flaws and prompt remediation of
these flaws including patching the
operating system application and
sometime triggering triggering new
software development iteration for
custom code.
Then we have the access control
managements. This include user
provisioning, review, deprovisioning uh
for the operational systems
and the production environments have far
more users. So strong access governance
is vital.
Then we have the change and
configuration management which include
controlled processes for requesting,
reviewing, approving and applying
changes.
And this ensure that system maintain a
secure and non baseline.
The maintenance activities include
hardware replacement, operating system
upgrades and end of life migrations,
schedule maintenance windows to minimize
the downtime, regression testing after
changes to ensure no unintended impact.
So regression testing is always done
after some changes to the application of
uh or software to check that the change
has no unintended impact on the
functionality or operation of the
overall system.
Our next topic is integrated product
team or IPs. So what are IPs? These are
multi-disciplinary teams comprising of
users, customers, developers,
contractors and security teams and the
goal is to deliver product faster and
with higher quality through
collaboration and shared responsibility.
So the IPS were originated in the US
Department of Defense for complex system
development
and the benefits of integrated product
teams is that they removes traditional
delays by having all the key resources
available early. It improves
communication, reduces rework and
increases the speed of delivery and
ensures security requirements for
example compliance and controls. They
are addressed from the very start of the
project development.
Software development ecosystem and
language security. So why software
security matters? So developer relies on
languages, tools and environments and
each of these introduces risk requiring
security controls. So security testing
tools such as SAS dash or tools we will
study these in a while they increasingly
integrate into the software development
life cycle and pro provide continuous
feedback.
So CIS are certified information system
security professional need broad
understanding of the SDLC processes.
They should not be coding expert.
They do not need to do the actual coding
but they should understand the process
to ident identify risk and required
controls.
So the programming languages include
compiled languages such as C and Swift.
So the complied languages basically they
are compiled to the machine code. They
are faster and platform specific and
they have the capability to protect the
source code. On the other hand we have
interpreted languages such as Python and
JavaScript. So these are executed or the
source code is executed at the runtime.
They are portable but they also expose
the source or source code. So we have
the intellectual property or integrity
risk such as mobile code tempering.
Then we have the database languages. So
these include the uh SQL, SQL and inside
SQL we have DDL data definition
languages that define the database, DML
or data manipulation language which
query or insert the data into database
and DCL data control languages that uh
is used for the access control of data
inside the database. So the security
impact is that database access control
and SQL injection
risk.
So then we have the type checking and
inside type checking we have the static
type checking that detects type errors
at the compilation time and this
improves integrity. Dynamic type
checking validates types at the runtime.
This is more flexible but may fail
later. Then we have the strongly type
which is uh safer for data integrity and
weakly type which is again flexible but
riskier.
So programming paradigms. So we have the
declarative which is the SQL that state
what to do and system handles how to do
it. So the security is via abstraction
and the access control. Then we have the
imperative or procedural paradigm which
is uh stepbystep command and uses sub
routines for consistent access control
checks. And lastly we have the structure
programming which include logical blocks
such as if then block and it is easier
for security review.
Then we have the OOP security or object
objectoriented programming security. So
we have in OOP the encapsulation which
hides data and restrict direct access to
data which result in integrity
protection of data inheritance which
reuses the secure methods and control
across subclasses.
Then we have the polymorphism
which uses the same interface but have
different behavior and it may introduce
logic misuse risk. Poly instantiation
include or has the multiple version of
objects for different clearance level
and this prevents parents attacks.
Next we have the markup and scripting
scripting languages security and these
include the HTML and CSS which include
the structure and style and generally
safe but can facilitate the injection.
Then we have the JavaScript which is
high risk because it include the mobile
code as well as the uh browser uh since
it is executed inside the browser. So if
you have the mobile code and browser
privileges that why we need spec
executional execution control and Python
which is versatile but it is interrated
language. So we must secure the source
and the scripts dependencies and the
runtime.
Our next topic is the software libraries
their purpose their benefits. So what
are the libraries? These are pre-written
code modules such as functions, classes,
scripts and procedures.
They in they are included in SDK that is
software development kits for operating
system, cloud platform and applications
and they provide reusable building
blocks for faster and consistent
development.
Benefits of libraries include speedy
development. So we do not need to write
the common functions from the scratch
each time. Librarian improves the
reliability. So they are widely tested
and they include community refined and
tested components.
Enhances compliance. So they has
built-in accessibility features and
payment processing modules etc. And
supports system interaction. So file
system access IO handling and device
control via drivers.
So security considerations of libraries
include so some of the security risk
includes that they are there are
vulnerable or malicious libraries which
may impact the entire application if
these malicious libraries are used
inside development of the application.
Then there are outdated libraries which
which have the known exploitable flaws
if they are used. And then we have the
open-source libraries which must be
validated and their versions must must
be tracked for usage inside the
applications. So the best practices to
use library is to always use trusted and
validated libraries only to maintain
internal approved library repositories
to apply updates and pages promptly and
track dependency versions and to perform
code review integrity checks and license
compliance checks.
Next is the software development tool
sets. So the purpose of tool sets is
that they support writing, testing,
debugging and maintaining software.
They improve collaboration and
consistency across development teams and
they enhance security by identifying
issues early in the software development
life cycle.
So common tool sets or tool types
include the source code editors. So they
include the syntax checking,
autocomplete templates and documentation
generation code repositories and version
control. So they uh include the
centralized storage, integrity
protection, revision, history and
developer collaboration,
debuggers and bug databases. They help
in identification of flaws, stepbystep
code execution and helps in tracking and
resolving the defects. Then we have the
compiles. Compilers which convert code
into machine readable binaries for
specific platforms.
Testing tools and security governance.
So testing tools include static code
analysis which review code without
executing it. And these type of uh this
type of analysis finds insecure coding
practices for example buffer overflow
risk. Then we have the unit testing
tools which verify small components
individually for correct behavior.
And then we have the data flow analysis
that checks how data moves through
functions to prevent errors or security.
So security governance of tool set
include that tools must be under
configuration management and page
management and only approved versions
and module should be installed and used.
Developers must follow secure software
development life cycle procedures and
request approval for new tools and
plug-in.
Regular audits should be done to ensure
tools support compliance and security
controls.
Our next topic is IDE that is integrated
development environment.
So what is an ID? So an IDE is a unified
workspace combining multiple development
tools into a single or one platform.
IDE improves productivity, consistency
and reduces the overhead of managing
separate tools.
Common IDE features include source code
editor which include the syntax
checking, autocomplete and templates.
Debugger which are stepbystep code
execution and uh helps in error
identification.
Build automation which include compilers
and build tools. Testing tools which
include unit test and static code
analysis. development integration
including Docker, Kubernetes and CI/CD
pipelines
and objectoriented programming support
include object and class browser and
visual programming interfaces.
So what are some security considerations
regarding the IDE? So IDE must be
approved, fetched and maintained.
So a compromised IDE means overall
compromised software. Therefore only
authorized plugins and modules should be
installed.
Then we have the runtime environment. So
what is a runtime? So runtime is the
full set of hardware plus software that
is needed to execute an application.
This includes firmware, device drivers,
operating system, libraries, APIs and
interpreters for interpreted languages.
So what are some security implications
of runtime? So vulnerabilities can exist
at any layer that is at OS layer,
drivers, APIs, interpreter and hardware
layer.
So therefore we must follow strong
configuration and change management
in so the interpreters may enforce the
security through sandboxing and
validation.
So high security environment. So we need
to use trusted computing base that is
TCB to enforce strict security policies.
PCB acts as a reference monitor
controlling system access.
So modern runtime examples. So
traditionally Windows and Mac OS plus
applications were the runtime
environments.
In modern days we use the internet of
thing devices such as the sensor and
smart appliances and edge computing
nodes. So we uh it require secure
networking such as Wi-Fi, Bluetooth,
firmware and data flows.
Our next topic is CI/CD that is
continuous integration and continuous
delivery. So continuous integration is
that developers frequently merge code
into a shared repository.
It helps in early detection of bugs,
conflicts and security issues
and CI uses full request manual review
and automated testing as well as
scanning.
Then we have the continuous delivery
that is CD where code automatic code is
automatically delivered to a testing or
staging environment. So it requires
manual approval before going live which
is common for regulated systems.
Then we also have the continuous
deployment which is fully automated
deployment to production after the test
pass and it require highly mature
automated that is quality assurance and
security processes.
CI/CD pipeline. It is end to end
automated flow that is from port to test
then build package and deployment and
security is inserted at every stage. We
have the integrity checks encryption and
automated reviews.
So testing and security in CI/CD
pipeline. So automation and
infrastructure as a code. So
environments that are built
automatically using definition files
known as infrastructure as a code. So
infrastructure as a code is basically
the phenomena where environment or
infrastructure is built automatically
through definition file. So this
supports configuration management,
consistency and auditability.
Then we have the automated application
security or apps sec. This includes unit
functional regression and security
testing for for example SAS and desk. So
SAS is static application security
testing and DAST is dynamic application
security testing.
So automated application security
testing is faster and more frequent than
manual testing.
So continuous security practices include
that security is integrated early and
throughout the pipeline. So we have the
automated scanners that feed issues
directly to the developer for example
via ticket and APIs. This reduces
miscommunication and speeds up the
remediation.
So what is the uh key takeaway for this?
So the CID basically improves speed
without sacrificing security by
automating controls, enforcing
consistency and integrating security
testing at every stage.
Our next topic is security
orchestration, automation and response
also known as soore. So sore is a
platform that orchestrates data,
automates actions and coordinates
responses to speed incident detection
and response and it goes beyond just the
seam. Seam is security information event
management. So seam basically only
alerts while sore also acts
automatically.
So it is you can relate it to the IDS
IPS where uh IDS only alerts or logs
while the IPS also takes action. So same
is the case with the store. So the
orchestration is that it integrates data
from seam user entity behavior analytics
IDs and IPS threat intelligence
anti-itching antimalware and scanners
etc. and then correlates events into one
actionable picture using APIs. For
example, we may have a fishing email
store links it to a user file ue eBay
behavior and malware alert.
So the second component of sort is the
automation
where which executes the uh playbook and
machinedriven actions after alerts. So
this reduces incident duration by acting
faster than humans. Example include
quarantining the infected machines,
forcing the password reset, deleting the
malicious email from all inboxes and
auto creating the incident response
ticket with relevant details.
So next uh uh uh next function in the
source is the coordinated response. So
this perform automated containment. So
basically it isolate the host block the
you can say source IP address or the
infected URLs run the scans and stop the
lateral movement of the infection. So
humans basically focus on analysis and
complex decision not the repetitive
task. These tasks are dealt with by the
store. So this produces a complete
incident case file for responders.
So these are some of the benefits of
sore. It provides us with speed. So
actions occur in seconds instead of
human uh involvement which may takes
minutes. It brings consistency. So it
follows predefined playbooks with no
delay. Reduces the impact. So the faster
containments results in minimized damage
and improves shock uh sock security
operation center efficiency. So it frees
analyst for higher value work or task.
The challenges of sort include that
false positive can trigger harmful
action for example locking out a
legitimate user. It requires tuning to
match the environment behavior and
reduce errors.
Our next topic is software configuration
management or SCM.
So the purpose of SCM is to ensure
integrity of software resources such as
the source code documents and
configurations.
So it applies configuration plus change
management to soft to secure software
development. So the item under controls
are called CIS or configuration items.
So configuration items example include
source code, libraries, configuration
settings, page level and requirement
documentations.
So configuration items must be uniquely
identified and changed to a formal
process. Too many configuration items
result in operational delays. So we need
to choose based on criticalities.
So baselines are basically a stable and
non good set of configuration items. So
baseline are used to define secure
settings required versions or functional
configurations.
Baselines are immutable which means they
change their changes require approval.
they should not be changed without a
formal approval or change management.
Then we have the version control. So
version control check tracks changes
using version numbers and enforces when
and how new versions are created. So
version control is implementing using
ver version control system for example
git and svn.
The security benefits of SIM include
that they protect confidentiality,
integrity, availability, nonreputation
and authenticity also known as DA of the
software components.
It prevents vulnerabilities from
uncontrolled or undocumented changes and
ensure visibility, traceability and
accountability in the software
development life cycle. Our next topic
is the code repositories. So what
repositories are repos do? So they are
centralized storage enabling team
collaboration. They support branching
allowing safe and isolated code changes
and they enable testing plus merging
back into the main code.
The security controls in repository
include confidentiality.
So X which can be done through access
controls such as rewrite permission
restricted copying and export of code.
Integrity can be done through version
control, rollbacks, control right access
and ticket based permissions.
Availability can be ensured through
central backups redundancy to avoid
single point of failure. Non-repudiation
through unique user ids, audit logs and
version history and authenticity through
uh can be done by verifying no
authorized changes using version
controls and backups.
Protecting the repository itself. So why
repo is a high value target? It is
because repos contains highly sensitive
data and can be exploited to insert
malicious software. Therefore, it must
be secured like any other critical asset
inside organization.
So key security controls to protect repo
include data protection inside repo. It
can be done through data loss prevention
tool IDs IPS to monitor activity and
detect the data exfiltration or code
exfiltration.
Similarly, we need to have the network
security controls such as secure remote
access using the HTTPS, TLS, VPN and
proxy so that our remote access is
encrypted.
Access
control can be ensured through risk
privilege approval for access and
perioding periodic access reviews. And
then we need to ensure the backup and
availability of repos through robust
backup strategy for the source code and
build assets.
So cloud repos offer resilience due to
their highly availability while
selfhosted repos they require strict
availability planning. So we need to
ensure that code is accessible when
needed even during outages.
Application security testing. So why we
need the application security testing?
It is because security must address both
the prevention as well as the active
vulnerability hunting. So retesting is
required due to legacy code, evolving
threats and limited resources and modern
program use full life cycle approach
that is the security testing should be
done through all the phases as we
studied during design development and
after development we need to carry out
continuous testing during the operation
and maintenance.
So some testing approaches. So this is
uh these topics are important from exam
point of view and the first testing
approach is the SAS that is static
application security testing. So in this
testing type we actually analyze the
source code and binaries without
executing them and it is integrated in
the IDE that is integrated development
environment and it provides fast be
feedback and it is safer for non
production. Limitation of SAS includes
that it is dependent on language or it
is language specific. It is harder for
non-developers because non-developers do
not understand the code itself and it
cannot detect the runtime uh or system
interaction flaws because it is this
testing is carried out on the source
code not on the live or production
system.
The next testing type is the dash that
is dynamic application security testing
which test running application through
interfaces and APIs and it is language
independent or language agnostic and is
useful for nondevelopers
and it is CI/CD friendly. Limitation of
dash include that uh routing the
findings to the developer. So since
developer do not do the uh security
testing the findings of the testing must
be uh routed to the developers for
fixing possible production performance
impact. So since it is carried out on
the production system, we may have the
performance impact and vulnerabilities
may actually reach the production before
detection because we are carrying out
the testing on the production system not
initially on the source code or during
development.
Our next test approach type is the IAS
that is interactive application security
testing. So, I combines the SAS test as
well as the pentest style analysis and
it uses analytics and machine learning
and has strong visibility in CI/CD
pipelines.
So, limitation of IAS include that it is
high cost, it is an emerging tech and it
has the language dependent and possible
performance concern.
Then we have the rest which is runtime
application selfp protection. So this
type of test runs inside the application
at the runtime. It detects abnormal
behavior and actively blocks the attacks
for example through virtual patching.
The limitation of RASP is that it may
result in false positive and false
positive leading to possible denial of
service and it has limited compatibility
and new skill skill sets are required to
run the rest
measuring the software security
effectiveness. So why we need to measure
software security? So meing software
security ensures security controls are
effective, compliant and improving over
time. It is critical for protecting the
applications, source code, tools and
development environments.
So logging and auditing basically
provides into the uh provides visibility
into system behavior changes and
anomalies.
So key concepts in measuring the
software security effectiveness include
auditing which is a formal review of
controls and activities against
standards such as ISO NIST and OASP
logging which is recording the system
events such as what was done who did it
when it was done and other important
metadata such as source IP address
timestamp etc. Accountability is the
ability to identify who performed an
action. So accountability is the who
inside the log. And then we have the
non-repudiation which is the proof
preventing a user from denying an
action.
Applications of logging and SDLC
auditing. So why logs are used? So logs
are used in change management to manage
system changes to approved request.
Logs are also important during security
incident to detect attacks, anomalies
and suspicious activities.
During performance monitoring, logs are
used to track the CPU, memory and
bandwidth usage to maintain
availability.
And in cloud monitoring we use logs
uh we use provider generated status logs
for outages and service issues.
So guidance and standards regarding logs
include the uh NIST SP800-92
and OAS logging cheat sheet and there
are some compliance frameworks such as
PCIDSS and ISO that mandate detailed
logging of the system.
So auditing across the SDLC.
So during requirement phase
uh we need to review the privacy impact
analysis data classification
and we need to make sure that the
documentation is complete. Then during
the design phase we need to audit the
risk assessments, the architecture
decisions that were taken and the
residual risk acceptance.
During implementation uh phase the audit
need to validate the code reviews the
testing carried out the separation of
duties control and we need to make sure
that proper security developer
procedures were uh carried out in
verification phase the audit check the
overall test coverage the result
achieved and to audit that the proper
approval was taken before the deployment
And the operation phase uh is the
ongoing audits of the live system and
this is the phase where most of the
activity occurs.
Risk analysis in software development.
So why risk analysis matter? It is
because risk exists across all the SDLC
phases from initial planning up to the
production system
and risk analysis in SDLC uh focus on to
protect the assets the likelihood and
impact of the threats to the system and
the cost effective mitigation of these
threats. Continuous risk assessment is
required because software environments
change constantly and risk must be
monitored continuously not a one point
in time such as yearly. So this applies
to development environment CI/CD
pipeline testing and live production
auditing the CICD
environments. So modern auditing
approach has moved from point in time
checks to the continuous monitoring and
basically automation perform the check
such as configuration scan every 24
hours or even faster as per the
requirements.
So in CI/CD automated security checks
basically run during the build or
deployment and if a check fails
deployment is large and this ensures
fast delivery fast delivery without
sacrificing or compromising the
security.
So benefits of auditing the CI/CD
environment include that it reduces the
human errors and ensure consistent
service builds because uh the manual
checking results in mistakes and spar
checks catch configuration drift in
production.
So what are some software development
risk types? So the first one is the data
risks. So the system processes sensitive
data and therefore we have the high
reach fact and we need to prioritize the
system by the data classification. So
lower tier lower tier lower tier systems
can be private point and therefore they
cannot be ignored. This means that if a
system is of lower tier,
it can be used as a jump box to access
other higher tier system there. So
therefore, security of this system
should also not be completely ignored.
Second is the new technology risk. So
the emerging tech has fewer controls and
has less expertise.
Therefore, the chances of
misisconfiguration are more likely due
to the less expertise of the human
resources.
Example, in early smartphones, we did
not have the full disk encryption.
Therefore, the risk mitigation of losing
or of a stolen uh mobile set data
confidentiality was limited.
Third is the code risk. So bugs,
unauthorized changes are malicious code
exposes confidentiality, integrity and
availability of the code and this
requires code review, change control,
testing and secure coding practices.
So where do the risk appear in the SDLC
life cycle? So in planning the
unrealistic schedules or lastm minute
security requirements may cause the
operational risk. During requirement
phase the addition of new features may
lead to internet exposure or the
requirement of card payments can
introduce the regulatory requirements
and threats. For example, the card
payment may introduce the regulatory
requirement of PCI-SS
standard.
During design phase, the technology
choices impact control
uh availability, remote access,
encryption and vendor login. For
example, if there are some technologies
that are chosen which are very vendor
specific, so we may be logged in with
that vendor for that specific
technology. For example, another thing
is the choice of the uh design may lead
to some limited encryption availability
and similarly is the case with the
remote access as well as the
availability.
So development secure coding proper
tooling and testing can mitigate the
development phase risk. So we need to
ensure secure coding we need to use the
proper tools and we need to carry out
the proper testing to mitigate the uh
risk during the development phase and
operation and maintenance. So most real
world risk occur during this phase
because this is the phase where the
software application is actually used in
the real world and during this phase we
need continuous patching monitoring
vulnerability management and threat
intelligence
risk assessment and treatment. So we may
use risk framework from ISO, NIST,
octave or FMEA.
And during assessment we need to
evaluate the likelihood as well as the
impact for each risk and we need to
develop the mitigation plan within the
risk tolerance of the organizations.
So risk treatment options include
mitigation which is the most uh common
treatment plan. Then we may have the
transfer mitigation treatment which is
include insurance
buying the insurance or if the uh
environment development environment is
inside the cloud the risk treatment uh
responsibility may be shifted to the
cloud provider. We can avoid the risk by
not carrying out the specific project.
And uh lastly we need to accept the
residual risk after mitigation
mitigation strategy consideration. So we
need the cost to evaluate because the
mitigation
incurs cost. Mitigation strategy result
in cost. So the cost may be direct in
the form of tools, software licenses,
consulting and support contracts or it
may be indirect such as productivity
impact, process overhead and training.
So measurement challenges of the costs
is uh hard uh it is they are hard to it
is hard to measure the cost of avoiding
an incidence.
Similarly, quality qualitating rating
helps in this regard. For example, using
the term minor versus uh catap
catastrophic risk and we need to use the
industry report for example where is on
DBIR for reference data.
So while presenting the mitigation
strategy to the management we need to
show the alternative options, the cost
of the mitigation, the benefit of
carrying out the mitigation and the
actual residual risk that will remain
after the mitigation.
So we need to tie the security benefits
to the business value such as usability,
mobile access and uptime.
So what is the security impact of the
acquired software? Another important
topic. So why acquired software is
harder to secure? It is because we have
limited control over the development
process as opposed to the in-house
develop uh software through SDLC and we
cannot directly enforce secure coding or
fixed vulnerability
and therefore risk must be balanced
against the cost speed and vendor
expertise.
So in a cord software we have the cords
that is commercial of the shelf
software. So the pros of cost is that it
result in faster deployment. It has the
support of the vendor and it includes
rich features. Cons include that we have
no source code visibility
and we must trust on the vendor
and these cards are high value targets
for attacker due to their wide use. So
these cards are used by multiple
organization and clients. Therefore they
are high value target for the attackers.
They are also vulnerable to remote code
execution, denial of service and
malicious modifications and mitigation
include to maintain inventory track
vendor advisory routine reviews,
intruding detection system, network
access control and compensating
controls.
Next is the open-source software. So the
pros of opensource software is that we
have the source code visibility. We have
the active community that fixes any
vulnerabilities or errors in these
codes. And of course they are free to
use and free of cost. Risk with open
source software include the flaws may
remain undiscovered for years even
though the source code is publicly
available. For example, the heart bleed
vulnerability that was found in
open-source SSL and that infected
hundred and millions of users. Then the
malicious code insertion in public
repository. So since these reposits are
publicly available the malicious actor
may insert malicious code and once use
these repository may result in
inclusions of these vulnerability inside
the organization's application and of
course lack of official support in many
of these opensource software. Mitigation
of these risk include to validate the
code integrity, use the official repos
to perform internal reviews and consider
commercial support options where
available.
Next is the thirdparty custom contracted
software. So the pros of this software
is that they come with the skilled
developers of the third parties that
develop these software. They have the
reduced project risk and faster
delivery. Risks include again the loss
of control over development life cycle
as opposed to the in-house development
and we must enforce security through
contracts SLAs and acceptance testing.
Mitigation of these risk include
contractual security requirements code
escrow detailed SLAs and independent
testing. The code escrow is that the
source code that is developed by these
third party organization are kept with a
middleman and if this contracted uh
third party goes out of business that
source code is then released to the
client.
the security impact of the shared eco of
the um acquired software in the context
of cloud services. So the cloud services
are basically they basically work on
shared responsibility model which the
cloud service provider handle the
physical rec security while the consumer
are are responsible for data security
and security assessment ability
basically decreases from these cloud
platform. So we have the more
accessibility in infrastructure as a
service, limited in platform as a
service and and least ability to secure
uh assess the security of these
application in software as a service.
Again the assessment consideration we
have the most control in infrastructure
as a service because we can assess
software deeply including the operating
system. In platform as a service, we
have the limited control and we mainly
rely on the vendor audits and SLAs. And
in software as a service, we have the
least control and we mainly rely on the
strong assurance reports. Reports may
include any of these types of reports.
Audits and assurance of the cloud
services. So independent audits provide
confidence when direct control is lost.
as we already studied and common
assurance framework such as these are
used for assurance and audits of cloud
services. So cloud providers invest
heavily in security due to the shared
customer base.
So secure coding guidelines and
standards define and apply secure coding
guidelines. So policies are the
highlevel direction while the standards
are mandatory and the guidelines are
recommended steps. So developer must
follow secure codic standards to protect
the CIA that is confidentiality,
integrity and availability of the data
and the applications. OASP and other
groups provide communitydriven widely
adopted secure coding standards and
standards prevent outdated or
inconsistent coding practices and they
are useful for auditing, scanning and
control implementation.
So what's the difference between
weaknesses and vulnerabilities? So
weakness is any flaw in code or design
but it may not be exploitable. On the
other hand, vulnerability is also a
weakness. But there is a practical
method to exploit it. So we can say that
any weakness that can be exploited is a
vulnerability. So all the
vulnerabilities are also weaknesses but
every weakness is not a vulnerability.
So some weaknesses are nonsecurity for
example performance and logic weaknesses
and CIS mainly focuses on security
impacting
weaknesses.
CWE that is common weakness enumeration.
So it is maintained by the MIT
organization and it is basically a
cataloged of software and hardware
weakness types and each CWE basically
includes its description relationships
in production phase platform
consequences examples and its
mitigation. So it is used inside the
static analysis tools training and
during secure SDLC activities.
CWSSS that is common weakness scoring
system. So this is used to score
weaknesses for prioritization
uh for prioritizing their remediation
and there are three scoring groups that
are used. First one is the base finding
which deal with the technical impact
privilege gained and confidence in
fighting. Then is the attack surface
which include the required privilege,
access vector, interaction and scope of
the weakness. And finally we have the
environmental which deals with the
business impact likelihood and
prevalence of the weakness.
Next is the CVE that is common
vulnerabilities and exposure.
So CVE is identifier for publicly
disclosed vulnerabilities. For example,
CVE-204-1266.
So this year basically uh shows the year
during which this vulnerability was
discovered and the number is specific
for a unique vulnerability
and this CVE also include its
description the affected versions of the
applications or operating systems the
references and the fixes of the
vulnerability
and then we have again the CVSS which is
common vulnerability scoring system. So
this is used to score the CVEes from 0
to 10 which is uh zero refer to none and
then it increases gradually such as low,
medium, high and critical. So the 10th
uh any vulnerability that has 10 score
it mean it is the most critical while
zero has no criticality.
We have three metric groups again base
which uh shows the exploitability and
CIA impact of the vulnerability temporal
deal with the uh how mature is its
exploitability the page availability of
that vulnerability and report confidence
and environmental is organizational
specific and it is adjusted for
organization's context. So CVE or CVSS
is used via NVD to prioritize patching.
NVD is national vulnerability database.
OASP top 10 web application risk. So
these are the top 10 OASP web
application from 2017 including
injection, broken authentication,
sensitive data exposure, XMR external
entities that is XXE, broken access
control, security misconfiguration,
cross-sight scripting, insecure
decentralization using components from
known vulnerabilities and insufficient
logging and monitoring.
So next is the security of application
programming interfaces or APIs. So API
is a standardized interface to system
functions without exposing their inner
workings.
And common types of APIs include REST,
SOAP, RPC, internal OS APIs and cloud
service APIs. So the rest API uses HTTP
methods such as get and post and exposes
API endpoints through URLs.
So API risk includes so their risk
mainly depend on the exposure of the
API. So the public API are publicly
accessible. Therefore they have high
confidentiality integrity risk due to
their public exposure while read only
public data have minimal confidentiality
concerns because they are already
publically readable.
So risk to APIs are similar to web
application security because API accept
and process external inputs such as the
web applications and web servers.
So basic authentication methods of APIs
include basic authentication such as
base 64 only which requires TLS. Then we
have the keybased authentication where
we require we need API keys which are
symmetric keys used for both
authentication as well as encryption.
Then we have the certificate based uh
authentication which may be one way or
mutual and certificate based
authentication basically requires PKI or
public key infrastructure and then the
federated/ SSO single sign on which
includes SL and Oath for delegated
identity and access
control must be granular such as role
based access control access control list
and attribute-based control and we need
to rest restrict access to data and
functions at the API layer.
Input validation and sanitization. We
need to treat all the external input as
untrusted. Escaping is protecting
against injection by marking content as
data. Then we have the synthetic
validation which which is used for the
correct format of the data. for example,
US phone number format and the semantic
validation is for correct values such as
valid area code. So use OASP cheat sheet
for SQL injection and input validation.
So protecting resources include APIs
must be threat model like web
application. An example include that the
Facebook view as API leaking the user
tokens.
Communication security of API include to
use the TLS and HTTPS for data
protection in transit and symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography ensures
confidentiality, integrity and
authenticity.
So different ways in which API is used
uh cryptography is used in API such as
for confidentiality we need to encrypt
data either uh pre-transit before uh
transporting the data as well as during
transit where the secure tunnel
integrity is ensured through hashes such
as hashing algorithm of short 256 or
shawan for data verification
authenticity is done through hashme make
and certificates nonrepudiation through
asymmetric keys and access control is
done based on key possession
logging monitoring and alerting we need
to log the authentication attempts
validation result IP addresses and
timestamps and we need to forward logs
to seam solution for monitoring
correlation and alerts
so API security testing we need to Use
functional security and performance
testing depending upon the risk and
tools used in testing depend on the API
type such as the rest or SOAP API and
OASP API security project provides
guidelines and top 10 API risk
secure coding practices and standards.
So why we need secure coding? It is
because secure coding prevent flaws,
bugs and vulnerabilities and it requires
standardized documented and
organizationwide practices. So CIS role
in secure coding is to define
requirements, validate controls but not
write code. So CIS do not need to uh
understand the code or write the code.
Security culture essential include clear
policies plus supporting procedures,
guidelines and checklists, training and
awareness of all roles and to align
security with organizational goals.
The core principle of secure coding
includes to have the secure by design
principle which include embedding
security at the very initial design
phase and to always assume attacks.
Secure by default is the conservative
settings of lease functionality and
private by default. DevOS sec ops is to
shift security to the left and integrate
security into CI/CD.
Security shifting to the left means so
it if it is the timeline
shifting security to the left means to
start security from the very beginning
or during the initial phases such as
during the initial design or planning
phase. Building security in software
assurance maturity model and BSIMM.
So mature secure development through
metrics and practices.
Next is a softwaredefined security that
is SDS. So SDS is a virtualized software
control security replacing hardware tied
tools. SDS uses softwaredefined
networking plus automation to apply
consistent and portable controls and
benefits of SDS include enhanced
availability. So control basically
follows the workload wherever they go
wherever they go across all the location
infrastructure neutrality. So one policy
applies to all type of operating system
and different types of cloud platforms.
Microteging is through automated micro
segmentation and fine grain rules per
workload. Centralized management is used
for unified view of policies across all
system automation and dynamic response.
So sword like orchestration
safe selfhealing and rapid mitigation
and supports modern architecture such as
cloud microservices and APIdriven
systems.
So that's all for this domain as well as
the course. I also have the practice
question for CIS on all domains. Each
domain has 50 practice question and
overall 400 practice questions which are
very handy and you must go through all
these question as well to prepare
yourself for the sys exam and identify
your strong and weak area. So that's all
please if you have any query or question
write in the comment and I will happy to
reply. See you in the next course and in
the next video. Thank you for uh going
all the way through this course and
through all the videos. I am uh very
thankful for your patience and for
watching all the videos.